violent protests broke out at Georgia
Tech in Atlanta the turmoil followed a
vigil last night for student scout Scott
Schultz a University of Police officer
shot and killed the 21 year old Saturday
Schultz was an LGBTQ leader on campus
the Georgia Tech senior identified as
neither male nor female
police now say it was Schultz who called
911 armed and suspicious person person
video shows officers repeatedly telling
Schultz to drop a knife before one of
them fired Mike Strassman is at Georgia
Tech mark good morning good morning
police found three suicide notes in this
dorm where scout Schultz lived and when
five hundred people are so gathered on
campus last night to remember Schultz's
life there was a smaller violent group
determined to send a message all their
own the night began peacefully as
hundreds gathered to light candles and
grieve for scout Schultz but that
remembrance descended into chaos
anti-police protesters disrupted the
vigil
they began screaming at officers a smoke
bomb launched into a police car it
sparked flames that engulfed the vehicle
and set off ammunition in the car I
don't know how many kids those really
loud drew Vincent a Georgia Tech junior
witnessed the violence flames were
pretty high so definitely a strange
night to be a student in a statement
Monday night scout Schultz's parents
urged peace but said they respect the
rights of those who wish to voice
opposition to what they feel was an
unnecessary use of force bill Schulz is
scouts father
it was definitely preventable if the
police had chosen to use non-lethal
force I've seen videos of them doing
that to mentally disturbed people why
shoot and that's the question that
that's the question why shoot in the
protest over Schultz is death to Georgia
Tech police officers were hurt
reportedly minor injuries
three people were arrested one of those
three is a Georgia Tech student all
right mark thank you